the driver i wasn't sure we'd see this
one today
oh oh no no
yeah but it's gonna still skirt down
right in front of the green i think he's
up there
going with the iron that's been the
strategy
for him all day the five iron god
bless you you mother i don't see it
try it one more time try to get chucked
just outside play just outside the right
edge just it's a tip
that's it that's what he needed to see
oh
phil making all three of those birdie
putts and
barkley at the 11th this 11th hole par
four
or desert 45 yards oh boy
look out charles is in a prickly pear
cactus i'm gonna try to blast it out
uh-oh nope
well where'd it go guys i think it went
just a few feet
oh dude phil's marching forward yeah
there we go
well i'm not sure
let me get a number
let me get a laser we got 98.
could make things very interesting here
let's go all right you're good you guys
got it all right let's go
concede give hold manning
and curry my bad all right
put a win on the board
now barkley that might be all right
yikes
oh okay stay there stay there oh man
good try
no that's nice i should have just hit it
hard fat ass
all four competitors from the same
yardage here 154
now charles got the driver oh bad
we got one more challenge drivable par
for the ford mustang maki challenge and
charles is first
don't try to hit it hard just try to hit
it fool